[Music]
what are your thoughts on the efforts of
the new folks SpaceX and yo musk what
are your thoughts about what Elon is
doing to see miss competition
do you enjoy a competition Oh what are
your thoughts yeah first of all
certainly you on
I'd say SpaceX and some of the some of
those other ventures are definitely a
competitive force in the in the space
industry and do we like competition yeah
we do and we think we're very strong
competitors I think it's again
competition is what the u.s. is founded
on and in a lot of ways and always
coming up with a better way and I I
think it's really important to continue
to have fresh eyes coming in new
innovation I do think it's important to
have level playing fields and so you
want to make sure that that you're not
giving different requirements to
different players but you know I tell
people you know I spent a lot of time he
places like MIT I'm going to be at the
MIT beaver work summer Institute over
the weekend here and I tell people this
is the most exciting time to be in the
space business in my entire life and it
is this explosion of new capabilities
that have been driven by things like the
you know the massive increase in
computing power things like the massive
increase in calms capabilities advanced
and additive manufacturing are are
really bringing down the barriers to
entry in this field and it's driving
just incredible innovation and it's
happening at startups but it's also
happening at Lockheed Martin I talked
about some of these like you know Maya
and Orion but you know we're in the
middle of what we call smart SATs and
software to find satellites that can
essentially restructure and re map their
purpose their mission on orbit to give
you almost unlimited flexibility for
these satellites over their lifetimes
so those are just a couple of examples
but yeah this this is a great time to be
in space
you